you know we've had some fun on the show
playing clips of the libs freaking out
um because row was overturned and
honestly i'll admit that it's it's a
little bit cheap okay it's cheap
entertainment it's a little bit mean
uh and i'm honestly disappointed in you
in the audience that you would
participate in this by watching me play
these clips and laughing at them um i
don't take responsibility personally i
pass the buck to you i play the clips
and make fun of them
it's your fault
for watching and laughing you should
know better than that you should
encourage me so today we're not simply
going to just play more clips of
hysterical libs and make fun of them
instead what we're going to do is we're
going to play more clips of hysterical
libs and grade them that's much more
constructive so we will be grading
the lib freakouts on a scale of one to
ten
ten obviously would be the most
impressive temper tantrum and then one
would be like a
a reasonable
intelligent
well articulated argument
so we can be pretty sure we're not going
to see any ones today but uh let's watch
the first one get
angry
this is atrocious this is war on women
how [ __ ] dare the supreme court do
this
you kavanagh [ __ ] you gorsuch for a
lying under elf when you were confirmed
saying that you believed that this was
settled women will die but as long as it
fits your christian narrative it must be
correct
white women of privilege will still have
access after their senators [ __ ] them
poor working mothers will not
young women who are victims of sexual
assault will not
women who found out that their child is
not viable in the third trimester will
not and who the [ __ ] knows what's going
to happen ectopically because
i think we've seen enough and i'm going
to give that it's a very strong story
let me give that a 7.5 grade out of 10.
it's solid you know she's got a lot
going for her starting with the
aesthetics she she has the angry
middle-aged woman hair thing and she's
in the minivan
her confused and terrified children are
probably in the back seat just like
huddled and
and
shaking in fear she's pulled up outside
of a whole foods i assume she's scowling
she's spitting using a lot of swear
words you can tell she's impressed
with the swear words that she's using
clearly a very unpleasant person to be
around this is the face of rage okay
this is this this face of rage is one
that many customer service
representatives have seen okay in this
world
this is the face of a woman
who doesn't understand why the checkout
line is taking so long overall
i think uh pretty nice performance so i
give it a 7.5 all the human rights are
going to start falling down
all right lgbtq plus community we're
next on the chopping block and birth
control
and possibly interracial marriage
so pretty much we're going
the only thing that's gonna have rights
in this country is
white men and guns
this is a tough one but i'm gonna give
it
uh this might seem a little harsh to
some of you and it's you know you're not
all gonna agree with every grade but i'm
gonna give that a six some of you
probably would grade it
higher than i would but um here look
here are the strong points okay we'll go
through this
she's crying
she's emotional um she's chosen the
least flattering angle and lighting
possible for this display all that is
good she's got some sort of weird growth
or mold or something
on her lip she throws a few curveballs
which i like i like to be surprised by
a lib tantrum and so
you know at the end she randomly
transforms into like a black southern
preacher with the way that she
pronounces the word what what we will be
serving white cake i had to detract
points because there's not a lot of
anger here
she's not yelling
worst of all she only talks about
abortion for about 10 seconds and then
and then she veers off into lgbt
interracial and all that kind of stuff
i just um
i felt like i needed a few more
pro-abortion talking points i needed a
little bit more from it so not a bad
effort but i gotta give it a six
[Music]
[Applause]
so the lord said i will wipe mankind
whom i have created from the face of the
earth
men and animals and creatures that move
along the ground and birds of the air
for i am grieved that i have made that
okay seeing probably as much of that as
we need to see
and i'm going to give that one a 10.
uh that one's a 10 as a commercial for
clorox bleach
for life's bleachable moments i think of
all the applications for a cleaning
product lots of people
that need to be cleaned lots of things
and items of clothing that need cleaning
i very much want to take the bleach and
pour it into my eyes
so that's a 10 out of 10 as a clorox
bleach commercial as a pro-abortion
meltdown i give it a four low effort
really does it make sense to you that
the same company who controls half of
online retail also passively eavesdrops
on your private conversations at home
what about the idea that a single
company controls 90 of internet searches
runs your google your email service and
gets to track everything you do on your
smartphone all that is happening big
tech look is more powerful than most
countries are and they profit by
exploiting your personal data it's time
to put a layer of protection between
your online activity and big tech and
that's why i use expressvpn think about
how much of your life is on the internet
sadly every site you visit video you
watch message you send all that gets
tracked and data mined but when you run
expressvpn on your device the software
hides your ip address something bigtech
can use to personally identify you so
expressvpn makes your activity harder to
trace and sell to advertisers expressvpn
also encrypts 100 of your internet data
so it keeps you safe from hackers and
eavesdroppers on your network what i
like most about expressvpn is how easy
it is to use just download the app on
your phone or computer tap one button
and you're protected as simple as that
so stop handing over your personal data
to the big tech monopoly who minds your
activity and sells your information
protect yourself today with the vpn that
i trust to keep me safe online visit
expressvpn.comwalshyt
to get three extra months free
i just feel like the way that we've
protested in the past has not worked
very well now i'm not advocating for
burning down buildings
i'm not not advocating for it
but
trauma and destruction is kind of the
thing that i love
so um if you guys want to join me in
mailing blood from your uterus to the
supreme court i already took the [ __ ]
bullet and did it first so
you know let's do it come on
you guys don't want to keep that [ __ ] in
your house
just mail it it's going in the trash
anyway keep it what do you normally do
with it
anyway uh
okay so this is interesting
we're back in the car
culturally appropriating for me again
we've got someone who's uh just at the
deepest level revolting
pathetic
desperate
committed a federal crime by mailing her
bodily fluids all of that are sort of
points that are that's that's going to
increase her point total maybe um and
and libs as we know are obsessed
with their own bodily functions and
bodily fluids they're like gross little
zoo animals in that way
but just overall i don't know i mean
there's no emotion there's just
i'm gonna give it a 3.5 i just couldn't
get into it i wasn't very invested in it
let's uh let's keep going so we all see
what has happened with this row versus
wade situation
we already knew this was how it was
gonna go down
dear white women
listen
your only play in this
if you value your life
is to shut
the [ __ ]
up
listen exclusively
to black
brown
and indigenous
women
femmes
and non-men
throw every resource you have
and use your privilege to back us
in every way
you are a big reason why we are in this
mess
from the day black brown and indigenous
people had contact made contact were
forced to interact with the colonizer we
have been fighting
back
the freedoms we have now are because of
our fight
and struggle all right
so
i'm going to give this an 8.5 i think
it's a very very strong
effort aesthetically
you've got everything you need from a
lib meltdown you've got a face
with uh many more holes than it should
have on it
you've got tattoos
overweight person
so strong starting point to begin with
in the car okay as always and then this
person who would seem to be on at least
three or four different drugs at once
starts ranting and immediately demonizes
half of the people on her own side
establishing herself from the outset as
the uber victim sort of marking her
territory
and she was making this all about
something other than abortion which i
know i docked somebody before for points
because of that but but she she's
keeping it abortion themed
she's doing the the victim hierarchy
thing there's a lot of different um
she's on crack and so she's she's
balancing a lot of things all at once
here and nothing she says makes any
sense or means anything it's rambling
it's very dumb
i could use a little bit more anger i
could use a tear or two
but overall i give that an 8.5 very very
good just a reminder because it seems
like everyone needs it uh not just women
get abortions
people with uteruses get abortions
trans people get abortions trans men
non-binary people
people of all genders get abortions
love you
first let me give it a 7 out of 10. uh
i've been making a lot of
body shaming jokes on the show recently
and i i told myself i was turning a new
leaf
i'm not gonna do that anymore but as my
producers they
sent me that video and uh
mckenna sent me that so i'm being led
astray
i'm not gonna take the bait though
because i personally think that um
brian stelter looks really good in a
purple wig
so i give that a seven out of ten
there we go that's what we're looking
for
10 out of 10 performance uh raw
emotional don't bother saying anything
making any argument using words just cut
right to the chase she's got the the
cinematography going on she hi she has
someone actually running the camera for
her for this meltdown
that is what we like to see from our
tick tock lib meltdown inspiring
performance happy ending for all of us
not for the left they don't seem very
happy but for the rest of us anyway